one of the guys who's been calling into
our show since almost day one is Pete
from Ocean View Delaware Pete garrison
is now here in the flesh here in New
York City good to see you Pete good to
see you sir and thank you
again look it's great to meet you and
Chris and Mike and and Lauren and the
rest of this great staff they have
treated me absolutely like a king and
for that I say thank well I got makeup
so you know makeup welcome to my show
it's the Petersons show there is what I
I thank you for your generosity and your
kindness well look at when you when you
you you stop calling for a few weeks and
months and then you call back and you
said you had Stage four yeah I was
pretty you blew us all away people owe
me a way to get the you know I'm the
second person in my family that's ever
had cancer and when I got that diagnosis
it pretty much scared the hell out of me
and because it metastasized it started
in the breast and then went everywhere
and and you know there's no cure for
this which I've learned to accept and
I'm gonna continue being the idiot that
I've been if I see sixty two that's
great if I don't hey it's been a great
ride well Jim Kelly was on in the flesh
and he spoke to you about you know hang
in there and you see how he's beaten
cancer mr. Kelly if you're listening
thank you and Jeff and Detroit right on
brother
right now you called us up and you're
like hey you know I'd love to meet you
and the gang edition well I come on up
to New York two other people you said
you wanted to meet on your bucket list
you say we're Smokey Robinson and who
Guy Fieri okay is Guy Fieri on the phone
line right now good guy you there I'm
right here oh my god I'm doing good man
I'm out here in California but I gotta
tell you something
you have you have grabbed the attention
of so many people and there have been a
whirlwind of folks trying to put this
meeting together
so glad you're down there in in New York
and we're making this happen and thanks
for letting me call in man this is
awesome
this this is quite a lot I did this day
couldn't get any better I've been a big
fan of yours for ten years and I'm
looking forward to the next big thing
but I will still every Friday night
starting at 3 or 4 o'clock in the
afternoon watch Triple D I'm a huge fan
and I love your humor and I love the way
you describe things and I love rich eyes
and for doing this I'm gonna spank you
sure cuz guys a Raiders fan I mean your
Redskins fan you know what the
inspiration that you're giving so many
people and the inspiration of explaining
what's going on telling people I you've
lived lived your life showing the
strength that you have bringing rich
into you didn't have to tell rich about
this no no but look what it did for rich
rich called me he called me at home we
talked about this I said I'm absolutely
in and you know we're doing is we're
showing that it it's you have such a big
family out there people you don't even
know care about you and want to help you
and want to be part of thank you and
you're giving folks an opportunity to be
involved and I hope this is an example
and my sister went to cancer I know
cancer you know and I'll tell you
something it's the strength of your
friends and your family in your
community that helps so much and you
letting rich and I in on this man I
really thank you enough guys thank you
so much I am so honored I am so blessed
like I said I've got well I've got a
great and that my best friend Chuck
Wagner who's sitting over there will be
up from Delaware he kicks me in the butt
and him and his girlfriend and and and
having people like rich you know
accepting in in and bringing me out here
and then this with you I am I am truly
blessed I am truly honored I feel like a
king and I mean that and I I I'm almost
four words but I'm damned
you're a superstar well and you know
what buddy and I think rich will tell
you the same thing the fans the people
that love what we do are what keeps us
going and I'm glad that you're Triple D
fan I'm on the set right now guy's
grocery games out here in California and
I told richness last night I said well
let's get him out of here says well
let's just get him to the show first
let's get him job but I gotta tell ya
what let me ask you this yes sir so we
you know it isn't it funny how the world
of food and the world of sports kind of
go hand in hand is there is there is
there a Triple D joint I've got to come
to Delaware sometime soon I haven't been
up there yet I got to come there is
there a Triple D joint I'm missing is
there a place you can give me the
insight on love it there's a couple of
places guy there's a place called
Porto's it's a nice little Italian
restaurant it's it's along with the
Triple D setup great food great pizza
they have all kinds of stuff there's
also a place called de fée Beau's in
Bethany Beach Delaware look at that
well I'm on it okay if you come out I
would love to meet you if things are
ready but this I can't believe how
blessed I am you talk to the guy for you
yeah I'm talking to Rich Eisen Guy Fieri
and the great style here who have just
made me feel like I'm important well guy
pop you thanks for doing this brother
you are you are you're you're the best
your salt of the earth rich well I'm
gonna tell you something buddy you're
the one that did the due diligence to
put this all together made it happen and
you know this is it we got to take care
of one another in tough times and rich
it's it's fantastic for having me ELISA
Pete yes sir if I make Delaware we're
gonna talk about this and and you stay
strong and you love your family and and
thanks for letting me call in guys this
means this is just this is awesome for
me too I think we're all feeling the
same way guy god bless you thank you all
the best to you good luck with your new
endeavor and stay healthy
thank you Peter thank you the mad guy
Guy Fieri everybody now I could I could
sing you
town that I mean like I don't I could
sing you smokey but that I'm in your
Sinatra voice well that's the only voice
of God my tears just wouldn't sound the
same
yes sir Pete you are the man dude rich
thanks for coming up here thanks for
making it to New York I can't believe
you did that with with guy I mean that's
he was all in man that was Wow a guy as
soon as he heard he's like done lock it
in locking in I I have never had such a
good day
I'm telling you the truth you know how
you doin
I know you throw it around like manhole
covers um as we've gotten into my yeah
I'm really a yeah I lost good but I'm
happy that's the most important thing
happy and it is great to see you here
and I look forward I look forward to the
next time we get to hang in New York I
would love to do that great fantastic
Pete from Ocean View Delaware on behalf
of everybody here on our show and all of
our listeners and viewers who've gotten
to know you we love your brother with
you loves you guys you knew thank you
very much you got paid you got everybody
I love you Pete love you guys for more
Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app